- Thank you very much, Judy
for the kind introduction,
and thank you and
also Dean Cohen
for allowing me to be here.
It's a great honor
and privilege,
and maybe more
importantly a great prince
pleasure to be among the
Fellows of this year.
It's an experience that
broadens one's horizons,
and I'm very grateful
for this opportunity.
So I've been working
on these fish,
and I hope I will make your
next hour worth your while.
It's not about humans,
but I'll show you
why fish even are much more
interesting than humans.
I think they're also easier to
understand, at least for me.
So I've worked on these
fish for over 30 years,
and have worked at different
levels of biological complexity
and organization.
I've worked in the field.
I've been studying
them in Nicaragua
since the mid 1980s,
an exciting time
when Ronald Reagan was
supporting the Contras.
There was a civil war raging
when I was catching fish there
in 1984 and '85 and '87.
Lots of people
were there to help
the people pick coffee or
dig trenches and wells,
and I was there catching fish.
It was a very strange time.
And I've been working on these
fish in Africa since 1990.
So for the last 30
years almost, I've
been studying them in East
Africa, mostly Lake Victoria
and Lake Tanganyika.
I'll show you in a
moment where they are.
And like I said, in Nicaragua,
we did some research.
At the end of the
talk, I'll talk
about a little bit
of the research
we've done in Nicaragua.
And for the first
or five, six or so,
I will talk about
cichlids in Africa.
Now, I had very
tolerant parents.
It allowed me to
collect beetles,
and I had a collection of
skulls and skeletons of mice
that I got out of pellets
that owls and birds of prey
regurgitate.
I had a tame magpie.
I also still have a tame
pair of ravens right now.
They miss me and
I miss them too.
And I was keeping fish--
catching fish with
my uncle, but also
keeping fish in an aquarium.
And I was observing
fish, breeding fish.
And so fish really are something
I'm passionately in love with,
but they're also a good--
there are good academic
reasons to study them,
which I hope I will
convince you of today.
Now today, I'll be talking
about cichlid fishes mostly.
I'll briefly talk about the
coelacanth and seahorses,
but we've worked on many
different groups of fish,
as you can see here.
They're incredibly diverse
in coloration, body shapes,
life history, social
systems, and so on.
And they're also very
successful evolutionarily.
More than half of all
living vertebrates--
so those are fish, amphibians,
reptiles, birds and mammal--
more than half of
those species are fish.
So fish do something right,
maybe better than amphibians
or birds and mammals.
And so in terms of evolutionary
success, one family of fish
is particularly successful
and those are the cichlid.
There are probably 3,000
or more species of cichlid,
so one in every 10
fish is a cichlid.
So there are many good
reasons to study them.
And when I was a
student here, I worked
with Kaleem who was a world
expert on the function
morphology of these
fish, how they feed.
Now, because I'm not sure that
I'll get through the talk,
I want to make sure
that I acknowledge
the people whose work I'm
actually presenting right now.
I have quite a large lab
right now with over 25 people.
The people whose research I
will mostly be presenting today
is Andy Kautt who will
be moving, as a postdoc
to Harvard in January,
Gonzala Machado
who is Argentinian
postdoc in my lab,
and Claud Kratochwil
a German postdoc.
I'll talk about their
research mostly,
but other people's
research as well.
Now, we have looked at
the genomes, as Judy said.
So this, over the years, became
easier and cheaper and faster.
But initially, we looked
at genomes of fish,
and we noticed that the
family the size of genes
is larger in fish, or tends to
be larger in fish, than in us.
And so we actually discovered
that there was a so-called fish
specific genome duplication that
occurred here evolutionarily
speaking.
So all modern fish, almost
every fish that you think of--
I don't know what you think of
when you think of fish, maybe
salmon or a guppy,
or I don't know
what fish you're thinking
of, I can think of many--
they all had, at
least initially,
twice as many
genes as you and I.
And maybe this is part of the
evolutionary reason for why
there's so many fish, because
they had twice as many genes
to play with evolutionarily.
And then duplicating
genes as one mechanism
by which one can invent
new functions of genes.
Because one copy of
the gene can continue
to use the old function,
do the old trick,
and then the second copy is
free to accumulate mutations
and change its function.
So having many genes
is possibly one way
by which you can make certainly
new functions of genes,
and maybe bring
about more species.
There are only a handful of
species, about 44 species,
alive today of
primitive fish that
branch off before this
genome duplication occurred.
And like I said, here's
a typical land vertebrate
as an example.
Half as many genes as
fish, at least initially.
Now over the years,
I've been interested--
and before I start
talking about cichlids,
let me tell you what the
question is that we are after.
What we're trying
to understand is
what we can read from the
genome from all of the genes
that an animal has,
what it might look like,
how it functions.
And it's been a long dream of
mine to work on the coelacanth.
Some of you may know this fish.
It's a living fossil.
Belongs to a
lineage of fish that
was supposed to have
gone extinct 75,
80 million years ago.
And it was a big sensation, this
is what the beast looks like.
There was a big
sensation when this fish
was discovered in 1939.
It was discovered by one
of my scientific heroes,
Miss Latimer, and
that's why the fish is
called Latimeria chalumnae.
And Miss Latimer,
she was a curator
at the Natural History Museum
in East London in South Africa.
And completely by
coincidence and surprise,
she discovered this
fish on the fish market
just before Christmas 1939, and
informed a famous ichthyologist
in South Africa that here's
this fish that had not been seen
alive for 80 million years.
They're very, very rare.
They live very
deep in the water.
And it was a really sort of
a scientific criminal story
to find the next fish.
It took until 1953 until the
fish was found on the Comoros
Islands, and it involved
a diplomatic incident
because GLB Smith, the famous
South African ichthyologist who
was after this fish, asked
the South African Air
Force to fly to
the Comoros Islands
and sort of could kidnap this
fish that they had found there.
This led to huge
diplomatic problems.
And for the next 20
years, only French--
the Comoros Islands were a
French colony at that time--
only French scientists
were allowed
to work on this fish
for the next 20 years.
Now this fish is
not really a fish.
If you know how to read
a evolutionary tree,
you can see that
this fish actually
is closer related to us and
mammals and reptiles and birds
and so on than to other
things that we call fish.
And in the Devonian, 420
or so a million years ago,
a lineage of fish-- sort
of like the coelacanth,
actually we now know it's the
lungfish-- that crawl on land
and give rise to amphibians,
birds, reptiles and mammals.
And so it was
interesting to ask what
in the genome sort of
predestined these fish
to become our closest
relative among the fish.
Now so we've looked at this with
a bunch of other colleagues.
This genome was actually
sequenced at the Broad
Institute here in MIT.
And we scoured the genome
for things that sort of are
not fish-like, but
rather are more tetrapod
land vertebrate like.
And one of the
things we found is
that there's a certain
regulatory element,
a certain gene switch, in the
genome of the coelacanth that
is already like the
switch in a mouse.
And you can actually replace
the switches-- take this fish
switch from the coelacanth and
put it into a mouse embryo,
and the mouse embryo will
develop a normal limb and not
a fin.
And this is, of
course, something
that must happen during
evolution that you change
from having fins to having limbs
so that you can walk on land.
And so these kinds of
things are things that we're
looking for in the genome.
Of course also,
living on land implies
that you have to have a
different form of breathing.
You have to protect
yourself from desiccation
and so on and so on.
And we've found certain hints
in the genome of these fish that
explain why this lineage, or
the closely related lungfishes,
were able to colonize land.
Now we've done similar
things in the seahorse.
And the seahorse, of course
beautiful and strange fish,
they don't really look like
a fish, as you can see.
They lost the caudal fin,
they don't have a tail fin.
The males become pregnant.
Not really, the
females lay the eggs,
and the females lay
the eggs into the brood
pouch of the male.
And there's actually a sex role
reversal where the females are
competing for the access to
the pouch space in the male,
and the males are coy
and are evaluating
whose eggs they should except
into their brood pouch.
So there are many
different things
that are very unusual
about seahorses
that we also explored
in the genome,
so get at the essence of
what makes a seahorse.
Now one thing that they're also
lacking are the pelvic fins.
These are the fins at the belly
that usually, in our case,
would be the hind limbs.
One thing that we noticed is
that these fish were lacking
a particular gene
called TBX4 and this
is a gene that is
switched on in any embryo,
like a mouse or
zebrafish, any vertebrate,
to tell the embryo
this is where you
will develop your hind legs.
Remember, the seahorse
lacks the pelvic fins,
so it lacks this gene.
And we did a CRISPR/Cas
analysis in a zebrafish
where we took out
it's TBX4 gene.
And lo and behold, it
lost its pelvic fin.
So this is the kind of
approach that one can take now
to test the function of genes,
and to functionally essay
whether these
ideas one has about
what is coded in the
genome about the phenotype
of an organism or the life
history of an organism.
Now let me switch
to the cichlids.
As I said, they are
extremely diverse.
These are all cichlids from Lake
Tanganyika, very, very diverse.
There are about 250 species
of cichlid fish that
only live in Lake Tanganyika.
It's the oldest African lake.
It's about 10 to 12
million years old or so.
And 250 species of
this one family, this
is as much biodiversity
of all families of fish
that we have in Europe
east of the Ural Mountains.
So the cichlid fishes are really
very diverse, and much more
diverse than any other
family or fish that
also lives in these lakes.
I'll come back to
this in a moment.
As Judy already said,
this is the distribution
of the cichlid fishes.
They live in tropical waters.
And I will first talk
about the cichlid and the
their of biodiversity,
the East African region.
But as I said, we've
also studied them
in Central America,
mostly in Nicaragua.
There are certain reasons
for why that's a good site
to study cichlids, which I'll
explain to you in a moment.
In East Africa, there are
three very, very large lakes--
Lake Victoria, Lake
Tanganyika, and Lake Malawi.
And each of these three lakes
has so-called species flocks,
or adaptive radiations of
hundreds of species of cichlids
that only live in
these particular lakes.
We now know-- and this was
not known 30 years ago when we
started to sequence
DNA of these fish--
how they are related.
And we also know how
old the lakes are.
And it turns out
that, for example
for the case of Lake Victoria,
it's pretty well established
at Lake Victoria is
only 14,000 years old,
yet there are 500
species of cichlids that
only live in Lake Victoria.
So this is the world
record for rates
of speciation of the
origin of new species
where you can have 500 or 600
species living in this one
lake.
It's a huge lake.
It's one of the largest
lakes in the world.
And when I say that 500 species,
I don't mean that there are 500
species throughout the lake,
but rather speciation--
as I'll come back to
the end of the talk--
is a local phenomenon, and
the biodiversity is summed up
over the entire lake.
Now one of the reasons why the
cichlids are so spectacular,
and why they're such
an interesting model
system for many evolutionary
phenomenon is their diversity.
And as Judy already
mentioned, if you
have 500 species
co-existing in one lake,
they have to go out of each
other's way ecologically,
otherwise they would be
out competing each other.
So each species has to
have its own well defined
species specific niche to
go out of each other's way.
And if you have 500 species
co-existing-- or even,
in the case of Lake Malawi,
800 to 1,000 species
co-existing in one
leg-- that means
that they have to have
incredible specialization
and incredible adaptations
to a very specific lifestyle.
So here we have so-called
ecological guilds that are
specialized to scraping algae,
or some of them are specialized
to feed on the babies
of other cichlids--
pedophages, they're called--
and they suck out babies or eggs
out of the mouth.
As Judy was mentioning, I'll
show you a video in a second,
they're mouth brooding.
So if they are trying to protect
their eggs or babies from being
eaten, but there's
several species
that try to suck out the
babies, or ram the mouth,
so that the mother will
spit out the babies.
There are even eye
eaters and scale eaters
that I'll talk
about in a moment.
Now let's compare this to
boring adaptive radiations,
like Darwin's finches.
There are only 14 species.
Of course, they are
famous, and if they
weren't called Darwin's
finches maybe they
wouldn't be quite as famous.
And their adaptations are also
reflected in the size and shape
of these builds.
Also the Darwin's finches have
very specialized ecological
niches that allow them to
feed particularly efficiently
on, let's say, hard seeds, or
getting small insect larvae
or of the bark of
trees, and so on.
And they're of course,
a beautiful model
system where one--
the grants at Princeton have
shown that natural selection
can act, and El Nino
is very strongly
changing the typical big shape
of finches from one generation
to the next.
Now the beaks of the cichlid
fishes, as Judy was mentioning,
are pharyngeal jaws,
a second set of jaws.
So the way this happens
is developmentally
and evolutionarily, the gill
arches that hold the gills--
this is sort of the last thing
the prey sees when it goes
into the mouth of a fish--
the gills hang here
on the gill arches.
And the fifth gill arch is
modified into its second jaw.
In this x-ray here,
you can sort of see,
this white area here are
very strong pharyngeal jaws.
And you can see the gut
here because this fish is
specialized to
feeding on snails,
and it has very strong teeth
and very strong jaws and muscles
to crush snails.
And what you see
here in this x-ray
are the snail shells in the
white contrast in this x-ray.
And so this last book
that was written,
sort of the cichlid Bible,
by Fryer and Iles in 1972,
shows the diversity
of pharyngeal jaws
in the oral jaws of these fish.
And we now know much
more about the genetics
of how you make these jaws
and how you make tooth shape
differences in these fish.
But this is the part of the
explanation for why cichlids
are so evolutionarily
successful,
because they can do things
with their jaws that other fish
cannot do, like for example
crack very hard snails.
There's actually an
evolutionary arms
race going on where the snail
shells are getting harder
and harder and harder,
and the pharyngeal jaws
are getting stronger and
stronger and stronger
to crack them.
So we've been interested in
looking at cichlid fishes
from many different standpoints.
One is to look at the
evolution of the coloration.
And as you can see
here, they're incredibly
diverse in body shape,
and coloration, and almost
every feature.
And I'll talk about social
systems and mating systems
in a moment.
Yet evolution has repeated
itself in the cichlids.
Convergent evolution
is quite common,
and this is something that was
only becoming clear once we
were able to sequence DNA.
Because only based
on DNA trees were
we able to tell which
species are related to which,
and thereby discover that
what we're dealing with
is a rampant convergent
evolution that
happens in these species
flocks and the cross.
So based on DNA
sequences, we now
know that all of these
fish here on your right
are descended from
one, if you will,
cichlid Eve that
colonized Lake Malawi.
And all of these fish are more
closely related to each other
than they are to those fish.
Actually, all of those
fish from Lake Malawi
are derived from a fish that
sort of looked like this.
It's a haplochromine cichlid,
a particularly successful group
of cichlids.
They're sort of the
cichlids of cichlids.
This fish left Lake Tanganyika,
the older lake, colonized Lake
Malawi, and then 800 new
species arose, and some of them
look very, very similar
to these other cichlids
in Lake Tanganyika.
That's, of course, great.
I mean, evolution
being predictable,
evolution repeating itself,
who would have thought this?
And this, of course, raises
a lot of questions to ask.
Well, if evolution
repeats itself,
what are the ecological
forces that shape
these ecological communities?
And what are the
underlying genomic
and developmental
mechanisms that
bring about these
similarities in body shape,
tooth shape,
coloration, and so on.
And this is what we've
been trying to understand
for the last 30 years.
I'll talk to you about lips.
You can see these very
pronounced hypertrophied,
big lips, and they
evolved several times
over in the cichlids.
Also I will talk about how
you make these stripes.
Most cichlids have
bars, vertical bars,
but some of them--
about a third of
the species-- have
these stripes
horizontal stripes.
Now this is an age old question,
and here at Harvard Stephen Jay
Gould famous paleontologist
has thought about this
and written in his book
Wonderful Life almost 30
years ago, what would happen--
he did a thought
experiment-- what
would happen if you rewind
the tape of evolution?
And if you tell your
students rewinding the tape,
they have no clue what you're
talking about of course,
because they don't know
what tape is, that you
used to record data on tapes.
Or I always ask myself, why does
the symbol is a floppy disk?
I mean, students don't know
what a floppy disk looks like.
And then event, if you were
able to redo evolution,
Gould predicted that evolution
would not repeat itself.
He would say that there's too
much contingency and too much
unpredictability in the
evolutionary process.
He thought that we would
not get the same outcome.
Simon Conway Morris,
also a paleontologist,
at Cambridge University, has
a very different opinion.
He thinks that if we
went to other planets,
if we were to discover
life on other planets,
he would predict it would
be bilaterally symmetrical
on the left and the right.
That those organisms would
likely have camera eyes,
and maybe even look human like.
Conway Morris has a bit of
a religious bent to him,
but in any event,
this is a question
that evolutionary biologists
and paleontologists have asked
themselves for a long time.
And these are the things, as I
said, I will be talking about--
these hypertrophied lips.
They have evolved independently
in Victoria, Malawi,
Tanganyika, but also in
the New World in Nicaragua,
and these stride patterns
that have occurred.
A good friend of
mine, Jonathan Losos,
we were both grad students
in Berkeley together,
just recently published a book
called Improbable Destinies,
where he sort of revisits
this issue of determination
and contingency on evolution.
And in very modest
ways, the I Gazette
that wrote about this
to sort of say, well
this is how evolution might
happen, or what is the answer?
Jonathan's book really
does not particularly
side with Gould
or Conway Morris.
He says, well it's
sometimes like this
and it's sometimes like that.
And I'll like to offer our
data for this discussion.
Now of course, convergence is
not only found in cichlid fish,
but it's a universal
phenomenon also in mammals.
So those of you
who've been to Europe,
you must know a
hedgehog, or this thing
looks like a shrew, or
this vole type thing,
and he's sort of
a punky hedgehog.
And this is actually a
very strange hedgehog.
This is a tenrec.
Tenrec's live-- it's a
particular lineage of mammals.
A former student of mine who
was a professor in Braunschweig
made this tree of
mammals, and could
show that the
tenrecs of Madagascar
actually are closely
related to elephants.
They're closely related
to African mammals,
and have nothing to
do phylogenetically,
evolutionarily with these forms.
My lab is actually, right now,
involved in several vole genome
projects, mole genome project.
And the question is,
how can this happen?
How can evolution repeat itself?
And another former student
of mine, Misha Milinkevich,
is now professor in Geneva.
He's actually looking
at exactly this question
of the similarity between
tenrecs and hedgehogs,
and shrews and tenrecs from
an even deeper perspective.
To ask, how do you
make these spines?
Is it the same genes,
or did evolution
find a different developmental
mechanism to make spines?
So these are all unsolved and
very interesting questions.
Now let me give you
an outline of what
I wanted to say after
this long introduction.
I'm going to talk about
handedness in fish,
about egg spots--
I'll tell you in a
second what this is--
evolution of color
patterns as I already said.
I'll talk about the lips.
And the last thing is to
talk about how we actually
make new species.
One of the most
incredible examples
for adaptation
and specialization
are the scale eating
cichlids of lake Tanganyika.
These are fish that
have asymmetric heads.
Half the fish have heads
turned to the right.
Other half of the
population of fish
that have fish to the left.
And this results in them
feeding on the left side
or the right side
of their victims.
And if you look in
these populations,
it's fantastic how, over
the years, when you collect
these fish, about
50-50 of the population
will be left or right headed.
The explanation for this
is negative frequency
dependent selection.
That is, if one of the mouths
becomes more abundant--
let's say that the fish that
have heads turned to the left
that attack their
victim from the right--
theirs victims
survive this attack,
but they will
smarten up know I'm
going to be attacked more
often from this side.
This will reduce the
chances of these fish
to be successful
in feeding scales.
And when you open up
the stomachs of these,
it looks like a book.
There are these
individual scales
that they have in
their stomachs.
So if these are disadvantaged,
they're less often successful,
then these will be more
successful the next generation.
And so this leads to this stable
polymorphism at around 50%.
And we've confirmed this.
This is data from Japanese
colleagues from the '90s,
but we've done this now in
southern Lake Tanganyika
before.
Now trigger warning, this is how
the scale eating cichlids feed.
On this innocent-- this is,
of course, in the aquarium.
They would not normally
feed on a goldfish,
and the goldfish is
way too small a prey.
But the point is to show
you how the fish actually
gets the scales from
the side of the fish.
And they almost always
will attack the offense
from a particular side.
So a right headed fish will,
80% or 90% of the time,
attack the fish from the
right side and so on.
And we were interested
in trying to understand
what is the genetic
basis of this,
or do the fish learn to
become a specialist in feeding
on the left side
or the right side.
These are fantastically
interesting fish,
because both the father and the
mother take care of the babies
both.
The mother and the father
will take the babies
into their mouth
and protect them.
But they're actually
are not so careful,
or we don't quite
understand what's going on,
but we have done
paternity analyzes.
We've been in the field in
Lake Tanganyika, collected
these fish.
And it turns out there are
many foster babies in the mouth
of the mother or the father.
It's not quite clear why.
There's some
theoretical arguments
for why this might
be a good thing.
But in any event, we've looked
at this now for several years,
and we understand a little
bit more about this fish.
We know that
behavior comes first.
So the little baby fish-- we
can breed them in the lab--
the baby fish
specialize on attacking
from the left or the right
side before the mouth become
asymmetric.
So maybe behavior drives this.
We also think there's quite a
large environmental component
to this.
And the other thing we've
just done recently--
and I'm excited about
this study because we just
got it accepted
yesterday-- what we've done
is to test fish
that always attack
from this side or that side, and
quickly sacrifice these fish.
And then we take the brain--
we take the left side
and the right side of the
brain, different regions--
and then ask which
genes are switched
on the left side or
the right side to see
are there genes
that tell the fish
you should attack from the
left side or the right side.
Now first of all, we find
pronounced differences
in which genes are switched on
and which region of the brain.
And I don't have time
to go into the details
of how we do these analysis
or what the brain regions do.
And then we can actually
test more interestingly,
are their genes
equally expressed
on the right side of the brain
or the left side of the brain.
A good part of the brain
is bilaterally symmetrical
obviously.
And so we looked at this, and
we find very large differences
that help us explain
how in the visual cortex
and also in the motor cortex
the different genes might
be contributing to this
laterality in the behavior.
So there's so much to
be studied in this fish
from the social
system of these fish,
the ecology of these
fish, how they feed,
down to the neurobiology.
Let me tell you about the next
thing, which is the egg spots.
What are egg spots.
Egg spots are these little
spots on the anal fin of males,
of actually, as it
turns out, about 2,000
species of cichlids.
All of the haplochromine
cichlids have these egg spots,
the males have these egg spots.
And all of these fish are
maternal mouth brooder,
and the thing that
Judy already mentioned.
Now this spawning behavior
in this social system
has large consequences
for these fish.
Because it limits
the number of eggs
the female can
spawn by the space
she has available
in her mouth, which
is not very much, maybe
20 eggs to 30 eggs
she can take up her mouth.
This has population
genetic consequences.
These fish are also
very philopatric,
they don't move
very much around,
and they come back to
where they were born.
Now this is based on
the evolutionary tree
that we made for
all of these fish.
We can reconstruct when did egg
spots evolve evolutionarily,
and when did maternal
mouth brooding evolve?
And both happened
here at the root
of all the modern
haplochromine cichlids.
Now what are these
egg spots used for?
So this is one fish.
This is actually work
that was done in the 1960s
by Wolfgang Wickler
in the Max Planck
Institute for animal behavior
where Connor Lorenz also
worked.
See, here's the male, beautiful
male, with the egg spots.
The male digs a nest.
He takes away those stones.
And he is trying to attract
the females to spawn with him.
For that, he will want to have
a very nice spawning area,
and he will want to look nice
and probably also smell nice.
There's probably chemical
communication going on.
And you can sort
of see here, he's
quivering, showing the
female his egg spots,
trying to entice her
to lay eggs with him.
There's the female.
She's interested.
And here's the male trying
to get her to spawn with him.
What happens then is
she will lay the eggs.
They're not fertilized then yet.
And the male will fertilize
these eggs externally
in the water.
So here's the female.
She's laying the eggs.
And here's the male.
He's nibbling at her anal fin.
There's the eggs.
She takes them up in her mouth.
They're not fertilized yet.
What happens next is that
the male will show her
his egg spots and the anal fin.
The egg spots have the same
size and color as the eggs,
and she thinks that she
has to pick up more eggs.
And so what she does,
you can see here,
she's nibbling at the anal fin
trying to pick up more eggs.
And the male releases
sperm into the water.
She sucks up the
sperm, and the eggs
get fertilized
inside of her mouth.
You think the fish are boring.
So this is how she
takes care of the eggs.
She protects them in her
mouth so hopefully no predator
can get to them.
So again, this spawning
behavior and the egg spots
evolved here at the base
of all of this diversity.
And we were able to
find the genes that
are expressed in these
spots that make these spots,
because we were interested
to see, how do you
make these spots.
Because clearly, these
so-called key innovation,
they might be part of the reason
for the evolutionary success
of these fish.
We ended up finding
a particular gene.
The details are not important.
And there's a way to show
where a gene is switched on.
These blue spots here,
the so-called in-situ
hybridization, where
you can visualize
where a gene is switched on.
And we did this in many
different species of fish.
And the interesting thing
is-- or one of the interesting
things is--
they are sort of egg spots
already in different fins.
They're part of the
coloration pattern
of many species of fish.
And we think that this
developmental way,
the genetics of making these
egg spots, was co-opted.
And this is something that
Stephen Jay Gould invented,
because he recognized-- also
Francois Jacob recognized--
that evolution is
not an engineer.
Evolution is a tinkerer.
Evolution has the
problem that it
has to work in every
generation, right?
So the fish have to feed, have
to survive, have to spawn.
And you cannot be radically
changing everything.
You cannot be like an engineer
and start with a white piece
of paper.
But rather these fish have
continue it every generation.
And the consequences, or
one of the consequences,
is you take an existing
way of making egg spots
and move them to the anal
fin from the dorsal fin.
And we think that this is part
of the explanation for how
this worked in this case.
Now more than 10
years ago, my lab
was part of a large
group of researchers
that wrote a so-called
white paper to the National
Institute of Health to
get money to sequence
genomes of cichlids,
and this was
done with old technology saying
our sequencing-- this was
done at the Broad Institute.
And finally 2014,
we published this.
We published the
complete genomes, or more
or less complete genomes,
of five species of cichlids
from Lake Victorian,
Lake Tanganyika, Malawi,
and some other cichlids that
are not evolutionary quite so
interesting-- tilapia.
I'm sure you've eaten them
all-- tilapia is an important
cichlid--
that's the most
commonly used species
in aquaculture in the tropics.
So if you've eaten tilapia,
you've eaten a cichlid.
Now when we sequenced
the genomes,
we had, maybe in
hindsight, the naive idea
that we would find the
answer to why there are so
many cichlids in the genome.
Because as I said, this
cichlids are singularly
evolutionarily successful.
The other families of fish
that live in these lake,
there are not so many.
So we thought, well,
what can you read on
of the genome of these fish.
And I summarized this in a
Scientific American article
a year or so ago--
these watercolors
were made by an artist
who, unfortunately, passed
away after this paper was
published--
summarizing what we had
found in the genome.
We find that the
mutation rate in cichlid
is higher than in
most other fishes.
So that's sort of a smoking gun.
We also found that
there is a higher
rate of gene duplication.
Remember that I said,
if you duplicate a gene,
you have two copies-- they're
usually right next to each
other--
the second copy is free
to accumulate mutation
because the first
copy will continued
to keep the animal
alive, continue
to do the original
function of the gene.
So we do find that, on the
evolutionary branches leading
to the most diverse cichlids,
that there was a higher
rate of gene duplication.
We also find an increased
rate of jumping genes--
of genes jumping around in
the genome that, more often
than not, tend to have
disruptive negative function.
There are some diseases that
are associated with them,
but they also can lead to the
evolution of new function.
If those jumping genes move
into the region of genes
that are switches for the
functioning of the gene,
it can actually bring
about new function.
So these are so-called
regulatory changes.
I'll come back to
this in a moment.
A gene is not only a thing that
codes for protein, but also
sort of switches in there to
tell the gene when and where
it's supposed to be switched
on, and which tissue,
and what stage of development.
So we find that, and we also
find a faster or higher number
of novel microRNAs.
MicroRNAs are interesting.
It's been know for 10 or so
years, and an interesting way
to regulate the switching
on and off of genes.
We find more of this.
So we find five or
six hints at why
cichlids may be so
evolutionarily successful,
but no real smoking gun.
But the genome seems to
be particularly viable.
Let me talk about the repeated
evolution of these color
patterns.
Remember what I just said
about the gene switches.
Color is very
important for cichlids.
In terms of mate
choice, I already
showed you the egg
spots are probably
important in decision
making who mates with whom.
The color patterns
are important.
It's been known that
many species of cichlids
are polymorphic for
color, so they can
have blue males or red males.
And females will tend to
prefer a certain color
over another color, and so on.
So in of sexual
selection in speciation,
color is probably important.
And as I said, cichlids are
extremely diverse in the color
patterns.
I mean, you can see this
beautiful color here.
By the way, the German name
for the family cichlidae
is buntbarsch, a colorful
purchase, aptly named.
And they're very
popular in the hobby,
because they're so
interesting, they're so smart,
they do so many
interesting things.
Now this diversity
of color patterns
can be divided, really,
into two major themes--
bars and stripes, horizontal
stripes or vertical bars.
This is a common pattern
that happens all the time.
But the interesting thing
is these horizontal stripes
can evolve, get
lost, and reevolve.
That's already an unusual thing.
If we map these
horizontal stripes
on an evolutionary tree, the
details are not important,
but we see that they come and
go at least 30 or 40 times
during the evolution
of cichlid fishes,
both in Lake Victoria,
and Lake Malawi, and also
Lake Tanganyika.
About two thirds of all
species have these bars,
and one third or so have
these horizontal stripes.
Now one other very
cool thing things
about cichlids that we
can hybridize them all.
At least in Lake
Victoria, we can
take any of those 500
species, by not giving them
a choice in the aquarium, we
can force the females to mate
with males of another species.
This allows us to
do genetics, which
is not possible to do
for many other organisms.
And also this is
probably due to the fact
that they are so
extremely young.
So in any event, we can
hybridized a barred species
with a striped species.
The F1 generation, the
hybrids, will look barred.
And then the F2 generation,
three quarters will be barred,
and about one fourth
will be striped.
So this is a Mendelian trade.
And what we end up
finding is that there's
a single region
in the genome, we
can map this phenotype
on the genome.
We have genetic maps for this.
We have genetic
markers, and we can
associate the phenotype
with the genotype,
and thereby localize the genes.
We can find that the gene
responsible for making
bars or stripes is on
a particular chromosome
in a particular place.
We can then test this gene.
So we can sort of zoom
in in trying to find
the gene responsible for this.
And it turns out to be a gene
that Hopi Hoekstra actually
has worked on here at Harvard.
It's a group of genes that
are responsible for melanin
in the skin.
So as these black bars are
made by black pigments,
and this gene is
involved in this pathway.
And it's known to be
differentially expressed
in the brain between
barred and striped fish.
But only in the skin we
find significant differences
in the expression
pattern, that means
in the copy number of
how often this gene is
switched on in the
skin of a barred fish
and of a striped fish.
So we can do further tricks to
verify that this gene really
plays the causal role.
So we can do again these
in-situ hybridizations
where we visualize,
through this blue color,
that this gene is switched
on in the right place
and at different levels between
these different species.
And we can do transgenics
and switch this gene off,
and make a different phenotype.
Or we can switch it on to
produce another phenotype.
Now interestingly, when
we sequenced this region
that we think is important, and
we think this is a gene switch,
we call this enhancer
A. Not very fantasy,
but we call it enhancer A
in this particular gene.
And then we
sequenced this region
in many different
species of cichlids.
We do find that there's
quite a bit of variation,
and it's not exactly
the same mutation
in Lake Victoria
and Lake Malawi,
and Lake Tanganyika cichlids,
but it's always this region.
Sometimes it's more complicated.
But what we end up
concluding is that this
is a particularly label
genomic region where mutations
can come and go and result
in these drastic differences,
and being barred or striped
several times over within very
short periods of time.
So evolution repeated
itself, and by some measure
used very similar
or maybe identical
genetic mechanisms
to reinvent itself,
which is unusual and
maybe not predicted.
Now let me talk
about the next thing
that we were
interested in studying,
these very pronounced lips.
These big lips are found
in Lake Victoria cichlids,
and some species
from Lake Malawi,
and some from Lake Tanganyika,
but also in the New World
in the cichlids that
I study in Nicaragua.
And actually there's
a very strange fish
in South America
in Argentina that
also has these very big lips.
Now Carl Zimmer caught this
our Angelina Jolie project,
where we're trying
to understand what
is the genetic basis
for these big lips.
And again, we can
do genetic tests.
But the first question
is, why on earth
do they have these big lips?
What are big lips good for?
It had been suggested that
having big lips allows
you to house is a lot
of mechanoreceptors,
because the surface
area is very large.
It has been suggested that a lot
of taste buds could be there.
It has been suggested that,
particular volcanic crater
lakes, when the fist
bumps into the rocks
to pick up an
invertebrate or something,
there are these sharp edges
on these volcanic rocks,
and it might protect the fish.
And the forth suggestion is it
might be acting like a gasket.
When the fish goes
into a crevice
to suck out a prey item,
it sort of seals the area,
and it can produce suction
and suck out the prey.
Now here's a
beautiful video that
shows you a particular
cichlid from Lake Malawi.
And you can see, it has very
pointed and narrow heads.
And you can see how it feeds
in the crevices, looking
for prey here in the lake.
So you can see lies on its side,
and goes into these crevices.
Now in the next sequence,
you will see the slow motion,
you can actually
see what it does.
So we think it has a lot
to do with creating a seal.
So it goes into this crevice,
sucks up water and prey,
and it can only do
this efficiently
by having this seal.
So we were interested in asking,
how do you make these lips?
And again, we were
able to cross fish
from Lake Victoria with big
lips and without lips to produce
hybrids, and then F2.
The F2 trick is that
you have recombination.
Genes get shuffled around
through recombination when
you produce eggs and
sperm, and then you
get segregation of particular
[INAUDIBLE] that might be
contributing to these things.
The same is true for the
Nicaraguan cichlids, where
some have big lips,
some have small lips.
We can hybridize them, and we
can map on the genetic maps
that we have how many
genes contribute to this.
And it turns out that
in the Lake Victoria,
the African cichlids
with big lips,
there are many genes
throughout the genome.
These are all the different
chromosomes of these fish,
and these different
color codes mean lips.
And we've also looked
at the behavior
to see how efficient are
they in sucking up prey.
We give them trials
in the aquarium
here where we have Plexiglas
where we drive food.
And the fish has to go into
these crevices and so on.
So we can map the genetic
contributions to this behavior
and to the morphology.
And as you can see, there
are many different loci,
something like 20 loci in
the genome of Lake Victoria
cichlids that
contribute to this.
So it's what we call
a polygenic trait.
It's a trait where many genes
have each a small effect
and contribute to the overall
large lips of these fish.
So [INAUDIBLE] would
probably not like this.
We have a core localization
of the lip phenotype
and the feeding efficiency.
And we find evidence for natural
selection acting on these lips.
That's the situation in Africa.
The situation is very
different in Nicaragua,
where we find a single gene but
huge effect on the phenotype.
This single gene, or
these locals here,
behaves like an Mendelian trait.
So you have either super
big lips, small lips,
or if you have two
alleles of this locus,
you have intermediate size lips.
So this one QTL, this one
genomic region, this one locus,
explains about 70%
of the variation.
This genomic region that
we're trying to home in on
is still a several hundred
thousand base pairs large.
There are several genes
that we have sequenced
the genomes of these fish.
There are several genes in this
QTL that might play a role.
We had previously done
expression studies
where we look at which
genes are switched
on in big lipped and
small lipped fish,
and we have a good
candidate for this,
but we haven't causally
confirmed this.
We have done whole
genome sequencing
where we've, in the
meantime, sequenced
several hundred
genomes of these fish.
And through a different
statistical genetic approach
called GWAS, we can localize
a region in the genome,
and it turns out to be the
same region that we identified
with the QTL approach with
this genetic mapping approach,
and we think this
might be a region that
has an inversion, which is quite
interesting evolutionarily.
So here we have a situation
where evolution repeats itself.
In Africa and in the New
world, producing these big lips
that serve the same
purpose, but probably
by a very different
genomic background
and a different
developmental mechanism
to make these big lips.
So Stephen Jay Gould might
be more along the lines
of what he thinks.
Now, like I said, lips are
also an important trait
for sexual selection.
There's a particular crater
lake in Nicaragua that's
only about 1,200 years old.
And in this crater
lake, we find fish
with big lips of
the same species
and fish with small lips.
These fish form
monogamous pairs.
They spawn and lay
their eggs together.
They defend their territory
against potential predators.
And this allows us to,
in the crater lake,
swim around or scuba around
and see how many fish have lips
and how many have no lips.
And if there was
random mating, you
would expect a certain
proportion of mixed pairs
or pairs with big lips and big
lips where male and female have
big lips, and pairs where
both male and female have
small lips.
When we do that, we find
statistically very strong
indication that they mate
based on the size of the lips.
So big lipped fish
like big lipped fish.
Small lipped fish like
small lipped fish.
And we can redo this in
the lab by mate choice
trials in the laboratory.
One interesting
thing is also, we
can inject Botox in
the lips of these fish
and sort of disassociate the
genotype from the phenotype.
Because presumably
the genotype also
implies some chemical
communication and so on,
so we want to sort
of tease apart
what is the
contribution of seeing
the big lips versus
maybe other chemical
communication or
audible communication
that these fish might be doing.
So we can actually
manipulate this phenotype.
Now let me come to the last
part of the talk, which
is to ask, well how do we
actually make new species?
What is the mechanism of
speciation generally speaking,
or why are cichlid fishes
such a great model to us
I ask this question.
Now you might
think, or you might
associate Charles Darwin and
his origin of the species,
with this idea.
But it turns out Darwin
actually did not necessarily
care about what species are.
He was very sloppy in his
definition of species,
and he sort of viewed them as
sort of sports or varieties
writ large.
His thinking about
species largely
came from visiting land shows
of breeds of cattle or sheep
or pigeons.
So he didn't really
think about species
as being something
special in evolution.
He didn't think that they
are the units of evolution.
And also, his book does
not offer us any mechanism
by which new species can arise.
His book is very useful
in many other respects,
obviously, in terms of natural
selection and this and then.
The person who really
affected the thinking
of several generations
of evolutionary biology
in terms of how you bring about
new species is Ernst Mayr.
He's of German descent, but
he was a professor at Harvard.
He lived to be 100 years old.
When I was a student here, he
sort of took me under his wing
and had a large influence on me.
His dogma was that you have
the best geographic conditions
to bring about new species if
they are separated by a barrier
to gene flow, a river or
a mountain or something
prevents individuals
from one population
to mate with individuals
from another population.
So there would be
no exchange of genes
that would homogenize
differences
that might be arising.
He viewed speciation
as something
that's very important
in a geographic setting,
and viewed it sort of
as a passive outcome
of geographic separation
where over many generations
you would have the
accumulations of mutations
and genetic
differences and maybe
mate preference differences
on one population and another.
Let's say once the mountain
or the river gets eroded,
they come together, they don't
recognize each other anymore
as a species.
So his biological
species concept,
the decision of who mates with
who, if you mate with females
that you think belong
to your species,
then this would
be the definition
of a biological species concept.
And he argued that his concept
of allopatric speciation,
so two different geographic
areas, plays a large role.
And natural selection played
really a minor or no role
in the origin of species.
Now, cichlid fishes
also inform on this.
And this is where we
moved to Nicaragua.
This is a lineage of cichlids
that lives in Nicaragua.
They live in a particular
chain of crater lakes.
Nicaragua's part of the
Pacific ring of fire,
and you have crater lakes
in Nicaragua, some of which
are 20,000 years
old and some of them
are 1,000 or 2,000 years old.
So this is summarized here.
All of these fish,
all of these cichlids
that live in this
chain of crater lakes,
came originally from the two
large lakes in Nicaragua--
Lake Managua and Lake Nicaragua.
So you have sort of a
generalist ancestral species
that somehow--
if you want to ask me later
on how that might happen--
that somehow colonized
these crater lakes.
And then you have the origin
of new species in these crater
lakes.
And each of these crater
lakes in Nicaragua
has private endemic
species that only
live in this one crater lake.
And again, some of
these crater lakes
are only 2,000 years old,
maybe 1,000 generations
since the colonization.
We actually have
modeled this, and we
think there actually may be
only a few hundred generations
in these lakes.
Now in these crater
lakes-- and this
is sort of showing some of the
variation-- there are currently
13 species described in these
particular crater lakes.
In these crater lakes, you
have no barriers to gene flow.
These crater lakes could be
only a kilometer in diameter.
There's nothing that would
prevent a fish from swimming
from one shore to the next
shore in a day or two,
and so there would
be no barriers
to gene flow in the
[INAUDIBLE] sense.
And so the fact that we find
new species that are private
to particular crater lakes--
and we can show this based
on genetics, and we can
show this based on ecology--
we know through a whole
bunch of measurements
that these fish lived at
different places of the lakes,
but they could swim
anywhere they want.
They feed on different diets.
They have different
pharyngeal jaws
that resolves in different
composition of their stomach
contents.
And we know again
that, genetically, they
are each separate entities.
So in a scenario
like this, where
you have no reason to think that
there's a barrier to gene flow,
these fish have become one
of the few accepted examples
for so-called
sympatric speciation--
the origin of new
species due to adaptation
and natural selection to
particular ecological niches
where presumably the fish will
be looking for their mates
in different areas or in
different times of the year
and so on where they feed.
But there's nothing that
would geographically
separate them from each
other as Ernst Mayr would
have predicted.
So this is one
example where we think
that sympatric
speciation is maybe
the mechanism by which
new species arise.
So let me summarize, I think
cichlids are a great model
system to address many
fundamental questions
in evolutionary biology.
They really are
spectacularly complex
in their social behavior, in the
ecology, and their morphology.
Now before I want to close--
- Cichlid babies
are in mom's mouth.
That's why the cichlid are
called mouth brooding fish.
Mom's mouth is both
nest and nursery.
- So this is the mouth
brooding cichlid.
- This one lets your
babies know to play,
and then provides protection
when it's time to come home.
It seems like a foolproof system
for keeping the young ones
safe, but it's not.
Let's introduce a predator.
- I hate to say, but
there's a catfish
that's smarter than a cichlid.
- --evolutionary process itself.
- You will see what
these catfish do.
- These catfish are
notorious parasites.
- So they are spawning,
and then they come in there
and eat the eggs of the cichlid.
- --fiercely defend their young.
The catfish you're able
to pick off a few eggs,
and they also drop a
few of their own eggs
knowing that the cichlid
mothers will pick them up,
thinking they're her own.
- They're cuckoos.
- And so the cichlid becomes--
- They put eggs in the mouth
of the female of the cichlid.
- The catfish take
off, never knowing what
becomes of their young ones.
Mother does her job, letting
the brood grow in her mouth.
Now, as in a bad horror
movie, like catfish eggs
hatch first and a baby catfish
feast on the cichlid babies,
gobbling down every single one.
- Inside the mother's mouth.
- Finally, the cichlid mother
releases not her own children,
but the catfish
cannibal kiddies.
Ironically, the cichlid
brood they destroyed
is the only mother
they'll ever know.
More irony, the cichlid mom
fails to sense the switch.
She treats the catfish
as if they were her own,
scooping them up to protect them
at the first hint of danger.
The catfish have
clearly won this round
in the eternal fight for
evolutionary dominance.
- So we actually
have looked at this,
and it turns out that
the cichlids that
coevolved in the same lakes
with these horrible catfish
are better in detecting when
they're being parasitized,
when they're being
manipulated by these catfish,
and they will reject these
foreign eggs much more
than a cichlid that
is evolutionarily not
used to being parasitized
by these catfish.
So there is, if you will,
evolutionary learning.
And the other thing we did
in collaboration with friends
in the Czech Republic,
we gave cichlids
experience in the aquarium
with being parasitized,
and they also learn
during their lifetime.
So there's
evolutionary learning,
if you will, and also experience
where they become more
apt at detecting that
they're being manipulated
by those horrible
catfish, and sort
of being brood parasitized.
So thank you very much
for your attention,
and I'll be glad
to take questions.